So, you're happy with it where it is?
>> No, it's going to go, 100% but I believe
it's going to go. It's 100%, yeah. The
whole thing is going to go. We have to
build a temple. If it was up to me, the
last time when they shot hundreds of
missiles, I would pretend that one
missile came from Iran and shoot it
down. The Jews and the Christian
Zionists believe that this must be
destroyed so that they can build the
third temple or Solomon's Temple, okay?
All right. So, this is the big question
in this war. The second thing that they
did is that they fired on Jerusalem
right next to the holy places. They sent
ballistic missiles that could have
destroyed the Church of the Holy
Sepulchre, the Al-Aqsa Mosque, and the
Western Wall. Ooh.
Brothers and sisters, imagine for a
second that you give 10 pounds in
donation and that 10 pounds is used to
buy food or bricks or whatever to help
the people in Gaza. But then just
imagine this amazing deed that you want
to do, but we turn it into a
money-making machine. How?
The Waqf is exactly that. They take your
money and the money that we are in this
Waqf, this building, and every single
time the money generated from that Waqf,
that building, is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20, 30, 40, 50, 60 100, 150 years
and this will be a form of true sadaqah
jariyah. I myself will be donating for
that, inshallah.
Click the link below and donate. May
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala bless and
preserve you guys. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers and
sisters and dear friends. On this video,
we're going to be dissecting
I would say five videos. Number one,
a direct threat.
Number two, an indirect plotting
um of uh using deception of the
destruction of Masjid al-Aqsa. Then
we're going to see the proof in the
pudding, should we say, when Netanyahu,
the Iblis, uh admitted few days ago, or
not admitted, but done an indirect
blaming Iran of the destruction of
Masjid al-Aqsa. Then we're going to come
to prophecy Young and Young um and his
assessment which is very the eschatology
of Jewish eschatology and what they say
about this one of them. And then we're
going to come to Islamically can will
Masjid al-Aqsa be destroyed? Now, the
plot and planning is there and they want
that cuz they're looking for the
Solomon's Temple and they're looking for
the the the the sehir that was they
believed that Solomon was indulging etc.
Cuz they're trying to reverse engineer
it. Let's go to the first video of this
individual. I don't know who this person
is. I couldn't manage to find the name,
but this is a video of them literally if
you can I think it's a repeat reporter
that the Masjid al-Aqsa is going to go.
Let's watch it for ourselves. So about
the destruction of Islamic holy sites.
Is that preserving this place and being
guardians over the house of God for all
people. So you're happy with it where it
is.
>> No, it's going to go 100% but I believe
it's going to go. It's 100% yeah. The
whole thing is going to go. We have to
build a temple. When you say that The
only thing 100% is going to go is your
janazah. Your janazah is definitely
going to go. Your burial,
um, is you're going to probably die.
Uh, you're going to before you Listen,
you in old age, you're going to die.
That's the thing is inshallah it's still
going to be there. Okay, your corpse is
going to go. Uh, but let's carry on.
Dome of the Rock has to go, MJ. It's
hard for me to imagine something more
incendiary. Well, let me ask you
something. The Middle East seems pretty
destabilized right now and the war, if
I'm not mistaken, is already here.
So, the Middle East is destabilized.
Hmm, I wonder why. Who destabilized the
Middle East? Was the Muslim just came up
and said we are going to destabilize our
nations?
Hmm, no, it's the democracy. The
democracy that you want us, you know,
deliberate the woman by dropping a bomb
in a school in Iran and killing 160 plus
innocent Iranian girls. You know, it's
that that you want LGBTQ for them cuz
that's fantastic. You know, transgender
rights and I'm a piano and I identify as
a tree. Yes, interesting. Now, we've got
this, um,
flipping Humpty Dumpty looking Zionist
rabbi dirtbag. Okay, let's make this
very clear.
The Jews and real Jews, real Jews who
follow the real um
the Sabbath. And these dirtbags are just
separate Look at Look at Look at this
clown. Look at this little
Look at Look at how he speaks. Look at
If it was up to me
the last time when they shot hundreds of
missiles, I would pretend that one
missile came from Iran and shoot it
down. Did you just hear that? Did you
just hear that? Yeah, okay. Now, to me
that's You can see that is
plotting with That's really plotting.
Okay. So, he's saying, "Yeah, you know,
Iran will say it came from Iran." Look
at it. They're looking for any excuse.
They're trying to weaken the Masjid on
the ground anyway. They've built all
these kind of tunnels, etc. Subhan
Allah. Uh but let's carry on. Let's see
what else this is. Humpty Dumpty shaky
Jewish.
You know
then all the Arabs will go against Iran
and it will be the end of the problems.
You make them fight with each other,
this bunch of lunatics. Okay,
interesting. Look at Look who's talking,
the bunch of lunatics.
What's lunatic about them? Think about
it. Who is the one that's causing
corruption on Earth?
Who is the one that's trying to reverse
engineer it for the engineer for the
Messiah to come, which probably say
Young Young is going to talk about it
now. We're going to assess it. Very
interesting. I want you guys to wait
till the end. Very interesting. The only
lunatics are you guys, you Zionist
scums. You are not true Jews. True Jews
know they were expelled by God and they
are under God's wrath until their
Messiah come. At least they're true to
their cause. We're exiled, we shouldn't
go back there. You dirtbags, Zionists,
dirtbags who are looking for loopholes,
okay, uh to ideologies, Zionist
ideology, to find You're trying to
reverse engineer it, cause corruption.
One of you guys Zionists bought Pornhub,
for God's sake. As a rabbi buying
Pornhub. This is how degenerate you guys
are. And you're trying to get the
to be as corrupt as possible so your
Messiah can come. Here's a video now of
Satan-Yahoo. Look what he says. Listen
carefully. An explanation of why Iran is
the enemy of civilization and the enemy
and the danger to the entire world you
got in the last 48 hours. In the last 48
hours they fired a chemical weapon on
civilians, on children. There's a a
children's nursery here. There's an old
man old people's home here. Civilians,
families, they fire terror weapons on
civilians and often they use cluster
bombs which are forbidden by
international law. The second thing that
they did is that they fired on Jerusalem
right next to the holy places. They sent
ballistic missiles that could have
destroyed the Church of the Holy
Sepulchre, the Al-Aqsa mosque, and the
Western Wall. OOH.
OOH, LISTEN CAREFULLY. The three holy
sites to the three monotheistic
religions, they don't care. They're
firing on everyone. Let's go. Okay,
interesting. Interesting. You see how
they have now kind of preempting, you
know, the Iran and send something
towards Al-Aqsa mosque, you know, etc.
Look, they know that's a thin line. They
know, oh boy, they know. So, you see
that from the Humpty Dumpty rabbi, yes,
Humpty Dumpty over there, yes.
If I was If it's up to me, I would shoot
you for rocking
you flipping lunatic, man. Anyways,
flipping jahil, flipping scumbag.
Anyways, so you can see clearly.
You saw that, yeah, okay. Now,
Islamically, before we go to Professor
Young's
explanation and his assessment of the
geopolitics and the eschatology in Jew-
Jewish
the Judaism, we're going to go to,
inshallah. Let's watch what Islamically
what we believe. Well,
and here the prophet makes a very sad
prophecy.
He predicts something that really hurts
when you think about it. He says there
will come a time when if a person were
to own a string of land like this, you
know, a horse's rein,
the rope we used to tie the horse and to
hold and to control it,
if you were to own some land just the
size of that rope
from which you could see Masjid Al-Aqsa,
that land would be more beloved to you
than the whole world and what is inside
it.
Meaning a time will come when Muslims
will not be able to live in Masjid in in
Jerusalem, will not be able to pray in
Masjid Al-Aqsa, and for you to have some
place you can even look at it from a
distance will be so amazing for you, it
will be better for you than the whole
world and what is in it.
Okay, that's interesting. And I have to
say that Sheikh
met him in person, may Allah bless him,
beautiful beautiful Sheikh.
Subhanallah,
Um, this is very interesting because I
looked at any, all of our traditions,
Islamic sources, Hadith, Quran, there is
nothing that says in Masjid al-Aqsa will
be destroyed. The great Israeli plan
might happen.
Meaning that all the Muslims will be
moved out or to a where you can won't be
able to see it. But it does not say the
destruction. Our Hadith says that
Muhammad will pray in there, Jesus peace
be upon him will pray there. So, if
anything, those lands are going to be
taken, but the destruction is not going
to happen. We don't know how that's
going to happen. Now, let's go where it
gets really interesting of Professor
Young uh is um assessment of this and
the Jewish eschatology. This where it
gets really, really interesting, guys.
Let's watch it for ourselves.
Most religions are similar.
Most religions require you to be a good
person. Be humble, be kind, be generous.
But there are certain aspects of
religions that are extreme, okay? And we
can we can call them eschatologies.
Okay? So,
the classic example is the Jewish
religion, okay? In the Jewish religion,
if you're
what you believe is that you you no
longer live in Israel because a long
time ago the Israelites pissed off God
by disobeying him. God told the
Israelites, "Do not worship false
idols." But the Israelites sinned, they
disobeyed, so they were kicked out of
Jerusalem. And they were forced to
wander the earth in the diaspora for
centuries. And so, what they believe is
that they each need to engage in an act
of redemption. Okay, and this is very
interesting because it's literally what
Allah says in the Quran.
When they worship the golden calf and
they did they were not they were God's
chosen people. They were God's chosen
people cuz they used to have worship of
one God when other people doing
idolatry, etc. And that's why it's so
harsh against kill the one that does
idolatry, etc. Um, and they disobeyed
God. They disobeyed God and not to the
to the point where they are now seeking
redemption, which is going to come to in
a minute. So, we saw that that they
started worshiping idols.
Let's watch. Humility of submission, of
piety to God, if they are to redeem the
whole Jewish people, okay? And when that
happens, when they recognize their own
limitations, when they recognize
how inferior they are to God, and submit
to God, then God will send the Messiah
to redeem them, and lead them back to
Jerusalem,
defeat the enemies of the Jews, bring
all the Jews from the diaspora back to
Jerusalem, unify the Jewish people, and
then build the third temple, so that God
can come to Earth and live with all the
Jews, and create heaven on Earth, okay?
That is the
Jewish religion
that most Jews believe. They've always
been demanding stuff. Okay, I'm not
saying all of them, because Allah talks
about Bani Israel, there were those who
obeyed the Sabbath, so we're not putting
all of them in the same category. But,
you can see that they have to show that
their inferior to God. They believe
That's why you saw that flipping unholy
schmoly, who's got a flipping sex shop.
Okay,
you know, where hijab humiliated. Yes,
you can see, he was saying God will
submit to to the Jews.
These people are crazy, nutters, bro,
nutters. They're challenging God. There
was one literally saying, "Yeah, we make
rain clouds now, we don't need God
anymore." These people are nutters, bro,
crazy, maniacs, lunatics. They're
lunatics, these Zionists. The actual
Jews who follow the Sabbath and stuff
and all, Rabbi Beck and them all, they
are the actual Jews who are like,
"Listen, we're going to wait for the
Messiah. We're not going to reverse
engineer and cause corruption in the
land, and you know, put degeneracy and
all this kind of stuff to the so
there's more corruption, so then the
Messiah can come." They reverse
engineering everything, and this is why
God has cursed them. Let's carry on.
Like, there are a lot of differences,
okay? But, but I'm just trying to
simplify it for clarity, okay? But, then
you have these extremes, fanatics,
who have a different
eschatology, okay? And these people
we're going to say are accelerationists.
And what And their point is that Listen
to this bit carefully because this is a
different kind of fanatics. That's what
I'm saying to you. It's not the real
Jews. These lunatic crazy Zionists,
these dirt bags most of them are not
Jews themselves, okay? And they're not
Semitic themselves, okay? And they're
the big They're the biggest
anti-Semites. You know, they were
anti-Semitic. They were working with all
kinds of people to kick them out. In
Iraq, they made false flag attacks with
their spies so that the Jewish people
can feel under attack and run to a
Jewish homeland. They cause
anti-Semitism and created anti-Semitism.
Not what I'm saying. The anti-Semitism
comes from the Crusaders and the
Christians and what they used to do. The
Muslims came and helped them to help
their own temple and honor them. And now
they're trying to destroy Masjid
al-Aqsa. Here you can see, subhanallah,
that they are now trying to reverse
engineer it, okay? Subhanallah. So, you
can see.
This is fine, but it's way too slow.
And it dissolves us of individual
responsibility. But, this is the key
here. Did you hear that? It's a slow
process, which means what? They're like,
"We need a loophole. It doesn't work. We
cannot wait this long. We've been exiled
for so long." This is why you guys were
cursed in the first place. And now what
they're doing is reverse engineering.
They're like, "No, we're going to take
matters in our own hand and we're going
to go against God's plan."
You need to listen to God's plan. He's
cursed you in order for you to be true
Jews, which you guys are fake, not the
real Jews, yes, to listen no matter how
bad it gets. No. They're like, "We'll
reverse engineer it." And this is the
reason why they've changed their
eschatology. Watch this. If you have
faith in God, then you should want to
hurry things up and uh force the return
of God as soon as possible. And you do
that by recognizing that
um
if you
actually, before the Messiah comes, if
you actually go and create the nation of
Israel, bring all all Jews back, build
the third temple, defeat all the
enemies, then the Messiah will come
naturally.
Okay?
And so, of course, most Jews hear this,
and they think that this is blasphemy.
It's heresy.
Because you are defying the will of God.
Good. That is real Jews what we're
talking about. That's why it's important
where I believe that's genuine
anti-Semitism to put all Jews in that
category. They're not. I know Jewish
friends. I've been to a
a synagogue. I know Rabbi Beck. They're
not the same. Real Jews follow this.
They don't go against God's will. These
maniacs, they are doing it. They reverse
engineer like I said before. And you
know what they're doing? They are
controlling the Like we know
these Zionists are in control of the
whole world and the banks and this
stuff. Zionists. Let's make it clear,
Zionists, not Jews. I'm talking about
Zionists. They are trying to reverse
engineer, and they are in their mind
they're like, "Oh, look, we control the
now." Which, if you honestly
listen, my friend, they they they are in
charge of what goes in your water. Yes?
To what you watch and all this kind of
stuff. And and and the reverse
engineering corruption and the the the
the heathers and heathers and stuff like
that. They all try to do it. Why?
Because they don't They're going against
God's will. You think you can manipulate
God into action. That is wrong.
That Oh, this guy even knows. He's not
even a Muslim or Jew. This guy even
knows. Listen, that's wrong. Okay, even
Dr. Young knows. That's the opposite of
redemption. That is the worst possible
sin you can make. Okay? And you.
Bloody hell. Even this guy knows. So,
this eschatology is considered a fringe,
an extreme, something to be ignored. The
problem though is that if you think
about it, what an eschatology really is
doing is creating a vector to force the
religion to move in a certain direction.
Okay?
And also, if you think about it, if this
is the case where eschatology is a
vector that forces the mainstream to
move in a certain direction, then we
whichever eschatology is the most
extreme, the most violent,
will be the one that wins out. Okay?
Okay, does that make sense? In other
words, what we're going to do today is
look at the most extreme versions
of different eschatologies,
because quite honestly, even though
these extreme versions are shared by
only a few people, they're the ones who
are working the hardest
to achieve their eschatology, and
therefore, they're forcing the religion
they are in to move a certain way.
Okay?
Do you see the problem now? So, you can
see what they're doing. You've seen the
blueprint. This is so profound that for
you guys, you need to share this video
far and wide. He, this brother Yianni,
just explained
the eschatology.
Then, what they've done
is he's gone and seen these Zionist Jews
with their extreme made-up new
eschatology to reverse engineer engineer
for the Messiah to come, and they're
doing that with the destruction, the
corruption, controlling the the
havens havens yes
etc. Um and they are using all these
kind of stuff to reverse engineer for
the Messiah to come.
I mean, you have to be really stupid to
do this cuz God is in control. Does he
not know what he's doing? Do you think
it's going to make you succeed? Like,
are you are you that stupid? Are you
that dumb? You're just going to have a
few moments of success. It's going to
You got to survive for 80 100 years
whatever. Eventually, it's going to come
to an end. God's not going to allow it
to happen. So, this is how stupid they
are. And Allah talks in the Quran about
those kind of Jews, cuz there were Jews
who followed the Sabbath, who God
praises Bani Israel. Okay? And we
believe they will go to heaven. Yes,
those Jews submitted to the will will of
God and Musa Alayhis Salam followed him,
they will go to heaven. We believe that.
Okay? So, subhanallah and I believe
they're Muslims, of course. Yeah. So,
that's what we're talking about. So,
this video gives you a blueprint and
idea how they are reverse
engineering, which I've mentioned many
times, guys. Look into this deeply, and
you can see from the videos, do not be
surprised if they try to attack Masjid
al-Aqsa. What we do know and that does
bring peace to our heart is what? There
is no Hadith or anything literature that
says Masjid al-Aqsa will be destroyed,
and we don't know. Could it be and
rebuilt? We don't know. But, what we
know is there's nothing that indicates
that. May Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
protect Masjid al-Aqsa, and may Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala liberate the people
there, and may Allah bring it back to
the lands of the Muslim and the power of
the Muslims so that the Christians and
the Muslims and the Jews can live side
by side side in peace. Real Jews, not
these
lunatic real lunatic maniacs who are
trying to reverse engineer their Messiah
to come. Till next time. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.